You mentioned analyzing one of your wife's
dreams that left you feeling hopeful
that will emerge from this chaos.
Okay.
Do you still feel this way?
Any new signs?
Well,
who knows,
right?
Because because the future is
complicated and no one's a profit.
I don't know what to think.
I think this,
I guess I already mentioned earlier in
this Q and a that on a global level there
is all sorts of reasons for real
optimism as far as I'm concerned.
There's reasons for pessimism as well,
but there's reasons for
real optimism and what,
look,
it looks to me like what's
happening is that the spread of
the western free market,
individualist ethos around the world
is producing a substantive increment in
wealth,
a substantive decrease in poverty,
and the consequence of that decrease in
poverty is also in places like China,
which by the way,
China is reforesting,
so that's pretty interesting.
China's now rich enough so that
it can afford to reforest too.
There's more forest in China than there
was in 1990 which is quite a remarkable
thing.
Anyways,
my point is,
is that on the global scale,
things appeared to be very positive
and,
but then in the West we seem to be
suffering from a crisis of confidence and
that's destabilizing us and
making us act foolishly.
And I don't know how much of a threat
that is to the integrity of our political
system.
Um,
and I'm so much in the
middle of this let's say,
um,
personally that it's hard for me
to have a clear head about it.
Now I'm very optimistic about
a variety of things that I see.
I'm very optimistic,
for example,
about the fact that so many people
have are coming out to these long form
lectures and paying
attention to high complexity,
educational and political
material on Youtube.
There's a real hunger for that.
And I,
as I said before,
the lecture tour that I'm on
has been extremely positive.
Um,
it's really something to see all
these thousands of people come out to
concentrate on getting
their lives together.
And I do believe that that's
why people are coming out.
And then,
you know,
I think,
I don't remember if I did a Q and a since
I did the discussions with Sam Harris,
but,
um,
I did for discussions
with him for debates,
let's say each of which
was about two hours long,
two in Vancouver,
one in Dublin and one in London,
UK.
And there were about 3000 people at each
of the Vancouver 8,500 people in Dublin
and something approximating
6,500 in London.
And the audience was very attentive
for the two hour stretch for all four
discussions.
And so I do see the,
okay,
I see more intelligence in the general
population say then I think we presumed
was there and more hunger
for serious discussion.
And I'm hoping that people who are clear
headed and sensible can push back the
idiot collectivist radicals
on the left and on the right.
We'll see.
Okay.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm hopeful because I think that people
are remarkable creatures despite their
limitations and the absurdity of our
existence and our proclivity toward
malevolence.
I think that,
yeah,
we can,
whatever constitutes our essence
is capable of transcending that.
And I think that people know that.
And I think the more people that realize
that consciously and start to implement
it,
the better off we'll be.
And so nested inside my extreme pessimism
about the structure of life and the
frailty of human character
is an acceptable optimism,
exceptional optimism about our potential.
So we'll see.
But I would also say to all
of you that are listening,
you know,
it is my firm belief that each of us
have a responsibility to set the world
right in the manner
that we are able to end.
That that is a fundamental,
that's a fundamental import.
I really believe in some sense it's
of cosmic import in the same way that
consciousness itself is of cosmic
import and consciousness reflects being
itself.
And so,
and I do believe that we have the ability
and the responsibility to bring new
creation into being and that
our ethical decisions help us
then our ethical decisions,
that the value of that new
being is dependent directly
on the ethical decisions
that each of us make.
And I think we can realize
that even though it's a
frightening thing to realize,
Marcus Perry asks,
you said,
the narrow bandwidth of TV has made
us think we are stupider than we are.
We'll internet center censorship lead to
the same problem once TV is supplanted.
Well God,
another incredibly complicated question.
You know,
whenever I think about censorship,
I actually talked to mark Zuckerberg
a while back and we had a good
conversation,
you know,
and Zuckerberg who I think is a very
straightforward person as far as I could
tell.
Okay.
Um,
is optimistic about Facebook and does see
it as a platform whose primary goal is
to connect people and mostly
at the personal level,
although Dave Facebook has made
forays into news provision and that's
complicated their corporate vision.
Now I am not a pro censorship character.
I do not like hate speech legislation
and I am absolutely opposed to compelled
speech legislation of the sort
that's been introduced into Canada.
I think it's violation of the principle
of free speech and free thought and I
think it's exceptionally dangerous.
But having said that,
you know,
nothing is ever simple and that's part
of the reason that things are so annoying
politically.
So you know,
one of the things that apple
and Facebook and so forth,
those large social media platforms had
to contend with say was the attempts by
organizations like isis to use
their platforms for recruitment.
Now let's say that I'm a
free speech absolutist,
which isn't exactly true because
I realized that there are the,
the constraints that he evolved in some
sense now truly in the English common
law system on free speech
and that they're necessary.
You can't libel someone,
you can't outright lie about someone,
you can't slander them,
you can't counsel them
to criminal conduct,
et Cetera.
There are restrictions on free speech.
Well,
but I think those restrictions
should be minimal.
Well,
let's say that one of the restrictions
that you assume should be placed on free
speech is that those that you are at
war with are not allowed to use your
platform to recruit,
which doesn't seem to be an unreasonable
proposition and is perhaps even the
sort of thing and it a
conservative or a libertarian,
much less a liberal or a
left winger might get behind.
Well then that means that you've defined
already a framework in which is that
censorship and,
or maybe I'm not thinking
this through clearly,
but is that censorship?
It's certainly self protection.
Well then having established the
principle that a certain amount of Mod,
what would you call monitoring of the
use of your platform is necessary.
Where do you stop?
And the answer is
it's complicated.
Um,
I think that what Facebook et Cetera
did with Alex Jones was a big mistake.
I think that was because,
well,
it wasn't just Alex
Jones that was punished,
let's say it was all the people that
were watching him and not everybody that
was watching him was an
avid follower of him.
Um,
some people were just watching him to see
what the hell he was doing and what he
was up to and that's necessary,
but you don't just sensor the one person,
you censor everybody that's paying
attention to them and then you make him a
martyr and you persecute
someone who's paranoid,
which all that does is validate his
conspiracy theories is conspiratorial
theories and the conspiratorial
theories of his followers.
Um,
I guess one of the things I've really
been wondering is if the wild and woolly
reality of Facebook and Youtube and
Twitter are actually sustainable in a
corporate environment or if the radical
freedom that was associated with those
technologies was only something that was
possible when in some sense all of that
material provision,
all the provision of that material was
outside the standard legal framework
because it was too new to regulate.
I know,
I can't tell.
I don't know if corporations can manage
something like youtube or Twitter or
Facebook for that matter,
because their internal
conservatism and there,
and I mean that in the,
in the temperamental sense,
their unwillingness to take risk is,
is,
is what I mean in that particular case
is liable to make it impossible for them
to be neutral purveyors of information,
some of which is going
to be extremely radical.
So
well,
so there's,
I have no conclusions to offer there.
I,
and I guess I'm glad in some
sense that these complicated,
these particular complicated
problems aren't mine to solve.
I certainly think that the production
of automated sensors is a very,
very bad idea,
but I'm also someone who's
constitutionally opposed
to such things as closed
circuit TV monitor,
monitoring of the general public as well.
And,
and cameras that,
that watch people at stoplights
and any automated system that,
that enforces the law or the,
or what's hypothetically the law
to me is to be regarded with deep,
deep suspicion.
So,
okay.
That's that.